juro por dios y ante el pueblo
colombiano defender la constitución y
las leyes de colombia
[Música]
el día 7 de agosto del 2018
iván duque márquez juró el cargo como
presidente de colombia con una promesa
poner en forma al país y prepararlo para
un proceso de desarrollo rápido
amigos desde entonces desde la
investidura de iván duque ha pasado el
tiempo suficiente como para que aquí en
visual político nos hagamos algunas
preguntas cuáles son realmente los
fundamentos del programa político del
gobierno de duke
es decir cómo quiere transformar
colombia puede llegar a conseguir lo que
puede suponer su paso por la casa nariño
la casa blanca colombiana pues atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
con casi 50 millones de habitantes
colombia es el segundo país más poblado
de américa del sur pero sobre todo es un
país complicado muy complicado fijaos
por un lado está el problema de las
guerrillas y el narcotráfico una de las
mayores industrias del país para que os
hagáis una idea colombia produce ni más
ni menos que el 70 por ciento de todos
los polvos blancos que se fabrican en el
planeta el 70 por ciento
y
por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar detrás de todo este inmenso
negocio que cada año mueve miles y miles
de millones de dólares se encuentran
poderosas organizaciones criminales
organizaciones dispuestas a controlar su
territorio contra viento y marea eso es
lo que explica que las tasas de
violencia sigan siendo muy pero que muy
altas en colombia' homicidios aumentaron
en 2018 por violencia tras desarme de
las farc según la autoridad forense del
país hubo 12 mil 130 homicidios el año
pasado 16 7% más que en 2017 y no sólo
eso tan solo en los últimos tres años se
calcula que más de 500 activistas y
líderes comunitarios han perdido la vida
a manos de estos grupos y cerca de
doscientas mil personas se han visto
desplazadas de sus hogares y aquí no
termina todo
además el l n un grupo guerrillero de
extrema izquierda vinculado también al
narcotráfico continúa operando 21 de
enero del año 2019 la guerrilla de ln
reivindica el atentado contra la
academia de policía que causó más de 20
muertos también cerca de 3000 antiguos
miembros de la farc podrían haber
retomado las armas y las plantaciones de
coca están en máximos históricos
los cultivos de coca en colombia
alcanzaron un máximo histórico en 2017
con 171 mil hectáreas
luego por si todos estos problemas no
fueran suficientes durante los últimos
años colombia se ha enfrentado a la
llegada de cientos y cientos de miles de
venezolanos huyendo del despótico
régimen de nicolás maduró se calcula que
ya hay aproximadamente un millón y medio
de venezolanos viviendo en colombia
rojo está muy bien y es toda una lección
de verdad desde aquí a todos los
colombianos
enhorabuena por semejante muestra de
solidaridad el problema es que todo esto
también supone una enorme presión sobre
la estabilidad y los recursos públicos
pero vale esta es digamos la peor cara
pero colombia también tiene otra cara
[Música]
veréis a pesar de todos los problemas
como el narco las guerrillas los grupos
paramilitares la violencia la corrupción
lo cierto es que durante los últimos 40
años el país ha registrado un
crecimiento económico medio del 3 8%
anual la clase media ha crecido y el
país no ha sufrido ninguna
hiperinflación
ojo no te pienses que eso es algo normal
no te olvides que estamos hablando de
américa del sur durante ese mismo
periodo de tiempo
perú bolivia argentina ecuador brasil y
bueno por supuesto venezuela sí que han
experimentado procesos de hiperinflación
en otras palabras que casi podríamos
decir que colombia es un modelo de
estabilidad sin embargo amigos he
esperado un momento porque el propio
presidente colombiano iván duque no está
del todo de acuerdo
[Música]
el presidente de colombia iván duque
afirma que no se conforma con el
crecimiento de más del 3 por ciento que
se prevé que tenga este año la economía
colombiana y se propone poner al país a
crecer por encima del 5% anual
y claro yo no me conformo yo no estoy
diciendo crecemos por encima del 3 y con
eso nos damos por bien servidos no
porque queremos ir por más y yo lo pongo
además en este plano colombia es un país
que tiene un ingreso per cápita en el
fin los 7.000 dólares pero somos un país
miembro de la ocde los demás países de
la ocde tienen ingresos per cápita más
de 30 mil dólares entonces me pregunta
yo en muchos eventos cuánto se tarda
colombia en llegar a niveles de ingresos
per cápita 100 años creciendo al 1 ó 20
años con creciendo por encima del 5 lo
que tenemos es que poner al país a
crecer por encima de ese 5% tomar las
decisiones para llegar a tener ese
crecimiento sostenido y eso es lo que
nosotros estamos haciendo
[Música]
si lo habéis escuchado bien 15 es la
meta que se ha fijado el presidente
colombiano ahora bien será capaz de
lograrlo como quiere lograrlo con el
panorama que hemos descrito parece
complicado no os parece pues sabéis que
no podemos decir si lo va a lograr o no
pero lo cierto es que este gobierno el
gobierno de duke tiene un plan lo que
visto lo visto nos resulta tan frecuente
verdad presidente macri muy atentos en
su reputación un plan que la verdad no
tiene mala pinta y que podemos
sintetizar en tres puntos principales
atentos
huyendo de la fiscalidad latinoamericana
amigos puede que esto resulte
sorprendente pero en general los
sistemas fiscales de los países
latinoamericanos tienen una
característica común tienen los
impuestos a las empresas más altos de
todo el planeta queréis algún ejemplo
atentos
[Música]
veréis la incapacidad de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para recaudar dinero de
las personas físicas de las personas de
carne y hueso ha hecho que concentren su
voracidad tributaria sobre el sistema
productivo
[Música]
es todo lo contrario de lo que por
ejemplo hacen los países nórdicos de los
que tanto se habla y ojo porque si por
lo general en latinoamérica la cosa está
mal en colombia es mucho pero que mucho
peor pero vale seguro que alguno de
vosotros se está preguntando pero a ver
alberto cuanto peor un punto dos puntos
pues no nada de eso
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea según el
último informe doing business del banco
mundial la tasa de tributación efectiva
de las empresas colombianas es decir si
tenemos en cuenta todos los impuestos
que se cargan sobre una empresa locales
nacionales laborales corporativos
entonces resulta que las empresas
colombianas se enfrentan a un tipo medio
del 71 9%
si lo habéis escuchado bien el 71 90%
del beneficio comercial de las empresas
es decir de la diferencia entre ingresos
y gastos sin tener en cuenta los
impuestos va directamente al bolsillo de
las administraciones públicas para que
os hagáis una idea cuando una empresa
colombiana compraba una máquina no podía
deducirse completamente el iva el
impuesto de valor añadido o incluso
existían impuestos que las empresas
tenían que pagar aunque tuvieran
pérdidas de locos y evidentemente todo
esto es algo que tiene consecuencias
[Música]
unos impuestos tan altos sobre el tejido
productivo afectan a la competitividad
de la economía colombiana y a todo esto
le tenemos que añadir la cansina
agotadora y pesada burocracia típica de
los países latinoamericanos vamos que en
estas condiciones es más fácil que cojas
por primera vez un palo de golf y le des
una paliza
jugando a tiger woods oa sergio garcía
que montará una empresa en colombia y
que funcione seguro que ahora entendéis
por qué los países latinoamericanos
tienen por lo general bajos niveles de
inversión bajos niveles de exportaciones
y mucha muchísima economía informal
y
en mayo de 2017 la economía informal de
américa latina' supera por primera vez
la de áfrica sub-sahariana
[Música]
de hecho se estima que más del 54 por
ciento de las empresas colombianas no
están correctamente formalizadas y claro
una empresa informal pues no puede
acceder a grandes contratos ni a
financiación bancaria ni disfrutar de
tanta seguridad jurídica vamos que no
crecen ni para atrás pues bien
precisamente enfrentarse a esta
situación es el primer gran punto del
plan de iván duque de hecho a finales
del año pasado logró que el congreso de
la república aprobarse una amplia
reforma fiscal su reforma fiscal
[Música]
básicamente la reforma ha consistido en
reducir la tributación a las empresas
colombianas incrementando ligeramente
los impuestos a las rentas más altas por
ejemplo a las personas que cobran más de
120 mil dólares y que hoy pagan pocos
impuestos y también incrementando la
recaudación por iva de esta forma con la
nueva reforma el impuesto sobre
beneficios se reducirá progresivamente
del 33 al 30 por ciento desaparecerán
además algunos impuestos adicionales y
se crea un sistema simplificado con un
único impuesto con tipos reducidos para
alentar la formalización y el
crecimiento de las pequeñas empresas
con el descuento del ciento por ciento
del iva que se paga en bienes de capital
y el descuento del 50% del ica y el
desmonte gradual de la renta presuntiva
en adición a un régimen simple que
diferencia las tarifas sobre todo para
las empresas en etapa embrionaria está
trayendo efectos
[Música]
y eso no es todo además la reforma
también ha creado incentivos fiscales
para los emprendedores para las
inversiones en grandes proyectos y para
las inversiones en el sector turístico o
en la llamada economía naranja y si vale
esto puede resultar más controvertido al
fin y al cabo porque unos sectores sí y
otros no pero bueno al menos parece ir
en la buena dirección no os parece
[Música]
la cuestión y tal vez es lo que ha hecho
que este proyecto resulte tan polémico
es que como duke va a incrementar
notablemente el gasto público y además
el gobierno tiene un elevado déficit
público aunque la medida supone una
reducción de impuestos a medio plazo lo
cierto es que a corto plazo implica
subirlos
es decir mientras las reducciones son
progresivas van poco a poco las subidas
se van a aplicar desde el principio por
ejemplo un recargo temporal sobre los
beneficios de los bancos y eso es una
gustado nada y si presidente duque usted
dijo que iba a bajar los impuestos no
que los iba a subir y los está subiendo
así que tampoco pueden resultar extrañas
algunas críticas prometer bajar los
impuestos y subirlos nada más llegar
aquí me recuerda es la primera decisión
que tome y puede ser un consejo de
ministros y subir el impuesto a la renta
de las personas físicas 7 puntos
ahora sí y ojo ya sabéis que en visual
político no nos gustan nada las subidas
de impuestos pensamos que el cambio va
en la buena dirección
latinoamérica en general y colombia en
particular tienen que tratar mejor a los
sectores productivos latinoamérica
necesita más empresas no más impuestos
[Música]
y la economía naranja
el segundo punto clave en la estrategia
de iván duque es promover con incentivos
fiscales con préstamos participativos
con capital riesgo y con aceleradoras de
start-up la llamada economía naranja
ahora bien un momento qué demonios es
eso de la economía naranja pues no no
tiene nada que ver con plantar naranjos
ni con las naranjas ni nada sino que es
así como se conoce a las actividades
creativas vinculadas con la propiedad
intelectual música diseño producciones
audiovisuales canales de youtube
arquitectura diseño de software arte
etcétera etcétera ser o ser un impuesto
de renta por siete años a todos los
nuevos emprendimientos en las industrias
creativas y tecnológicas porque son los
años donde surgen esos empresarios girar
os habéis dado cuenta que cada vez hay
más películas y series rodadas en
colombia e incluso cada vez hay más
producciones de plataformas como netflix
o prime vídeo que se realizan en este
país y todo esto no es casual tiene
una explicación
en 2012 se aprobó la ley 1556 que
contemplaba importantes incentivos
fiscales y ayudas a la producción de
películas y rodajes cinematográficos que
en colombia se buscaba de esa forma no
sólo hacer crecer la industria nacional
del cine sino también favorecer una
imagen mejor del país en el mundo el
resultado es que el número de
producciones en colombia se disparó
pues bien ahora iván duque quiero hacer
lo mismo con todas las actividades que
quedan dentro de esta economía naranja y
ojo porque no es ninguna tontería a día
de hoy la economía naranja en colombia
es casi tres veces más grande que la
industria del café y casi tan grande
como todo el sector de la minería
hablamos de actividades económicas cuyo
comercio a nivel mundial crece a ritmos
del 7% anual y cuyo valor en 2015 ya
superaba los 500 mil millones de dólares
la economía naranja es mucho más que el
nuevo petróleo las reservas de petróleo
son limitadas pero la creatividad es
ilimitada tenemos que ser conscientes
que el patrimonio más importante que
tenemos en una sociedad es el talento de
su gente
iván duke pues bien para lograr este
propósito el gobierno está poniendo en
marcha planes de financiación
participativa iniciativas de capital
riesgo centros de emprendimiento y
exenciones fiscales ahora funcionará
tendrá realmente esta economía naranja
la capacidad de transformar colombia
sólo el tiempo podrá decirlo pero sabéis
que es un plan que suena bien
[Música]
y al menos es un plan diferente y ligado
al capital humano a las personas y no a
los recursos naturales ni a las grandes
empresas cercanas a los gobiernos que
por desgracia suele ser lo habitual en
este continente en latinoamérica pero
aquí no termina todo aún nos queda otro
pilar esencial en toda esta estrategia
las nuevas apuestas
no es estrictamente una idea de iván
duque pero parece que el nuevo gobierno
la ha comprado
colombia quiere convertirse en el gran
jugador en el mercado mundial del
cannabis medicinal un sector que crece
como la espuma y que se espera se
convierta en un mercado de casi 50 mil
millones para el año 2025 y es que
colombia aspira a tener una cuota de más
del 40% es decir hablamos de un sector
enorme y todo un empujón para la
economía colombiana especialmente para
la economía de las zonas rurales más
pobres nos llama la posibilidad de ser
jugadores muy importantes a nivel
mundial en materia de exportaciones las
estimaciones hablan de que efectivamente
podríamos estar en niveles de unos 6000
millones de dólares anuales de
exportaciones
saúl pineda viceministro de desarrollo
empresarial
pues bien junto a la de las puntiagudas
plantas verdes la otra gran apuesta en
el gobierno pasa por impulsar el
fracking para incrementar la producción
petrolera
de momento ya se han aprobado cuatro
proyectos pilotos que podrían producir
más de 400 mil barriles diarios cuando
estén plenamente operativos esto
supondría incrementar la producción de
petróleo de colombia en nada menos que
casi un 50 por ciento
[Música]
el fin con todas estas medidas y con una
mayor inversión en infraestructuras y en
educación es como el gobierno de iván
duque parece querer conseguir su
objetivo de elevar el crecimiento
económico de colombia por encima del 5%
la gran pregunta lo conseguirá
en visual política estaremos muy atentos
pero las cosas como son
- no pintan nada mal por supuesto hay
otras cuestiones por resolver y que
pueden generar muchos problemas por
ejemplo el fuerte incremento del gasto
público o la constante devaluación del
peso colombiano y desde luego el
gobierno del señor duque no se ha
limitado a tomar medidas solo en el
campo económico qué pasa con los narcos
qué hacer con la seguridad que está
haciendo en política exterior pues
amigos de todo eso hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en visual político
así que si te interesa el tema y aún no
lo has hecho suscríbete y ahora si os
parece y esperamos vuestros comentarios
para que nos contéis qué opinión tenéis
de duke y de los cambios que está
impulsando como siempre un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]